abriegelung von risikogebieten über die
nachbarländer haben wir ja bereits
gesprochen jetzt lass uns mal
innerdeutsch sprechen was hätte das denn
zu bedeuten also das klingt schlimmer
als es jetzt also es klingt schlimmer
als es der wirklichkeit werden würde
jedenfalls das was momentan in der
planung oder in der überlegung ist es
geht darum lokal zu handeln also nicht
wie ein ganzes bundesland nicht für eine
ganze stadt nicht für ein ganz ganz lang
sondern zu überlegen wenn in einem bin
in einem hotspot die lage außer
kontrolle zu geraten droht ob man dann
dort sogenannte umkreis beschränkungen
das ist ein begriff der kommt eigentlich
aus dem verkehrswesen und gilt man kann
führerscheine im umkreis beschränken zum
beispiel für epileptiker dass die nur in
einem bestimmten radius fahren dürfen
warum sich medikamente zurückzuholen und
dieser begriff sollen übertragen werden
auf kommunen kleinere kommunen das ist
nur machbar in kleineren ländlichen
gebieten oder aber wenn ein wenn ein
wohnblock irgendwo irgendwo dann halt
befallen ist lokal reagieren und lokal
handeln um nicht flächendeckend
irgendetwas zu machen auch da wurde
gelten warenverkehr ist gegeben
bestimmte sachen werden weiter
funktionieren natürlich müssen die
pfleger rein und rein und raus vom
arbeit diskutiert wird darüber
das ist alles jetzt nicht in der
schublade aber das ist in der diskussion
drin da gibt es auch papiere zu und das
wird diskutiert und dann wird deshalb
von fall zu fall je nachdem wie es denn
tatsächlich kommt kommt es auf die
agenda und dann wird's beschlossen oder
nicht beschlossen für wie realistisch
ist das denn und wie würde das überhaupt
aussehen will man dann einfach kleine
gemeinden einmal rundherum mit polizei
absperren und wie reagieren die menschen
wir hatten ähnliche fälle hatten wir
schon wir haben ja schon in
südostdeutschland man bei diesen einen
kreis wir erinnern uns an die geschichte
wo die leute stiften gegangen sind wo
einfach 100 leute ausgebrochen altenheim
besonders gerne noch so und da hatten
wir schon mal eine kommune die war
abgeriegelt so das war ein absoluter
hotspot und die war abgeriegelt und das
war auch machbar das war für die leute
überhaupt nicht schön aber daran ist die
deutsche wirtschaft nicht zugrunde
gegangen und auch die region ist daran
nicht zugrunde gegangen man hat es also
lokal blick bekämpft und glaube es war
es in gütersloh oder hatten wir auch
schon die bilder mit dem bau zeugen die
um zwei wohnblocks standen
das ist machbar das hat schon
stattgefunden und die frage ist ob wir
das im winter der wirklich lange wir
hatten ja eine kurze infektions phase im
frühjahr jetzt kommen oktober november
dezember januar februar märz april durch
diese kalten dunklen monate müssten wir
durchkommen bevor es wieder wärmer wird
jetzt kommt also
wirklich lange phase mit
infektionsgeschehen und mit
rahmenbedingungen die wir gar nicht
kennen
die politik auch noch nicht dich nicht
kennt und das ist ein instrument aus dem
besteckkasten mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren